how'd you get that name man [ __ ]
honestly we put the mic in front of you
and and the applesauce or juice up it's
[ __ ] that's amen I respect it but I
like that bro but um it's better than
lean right
you can't get addicted to Honest Kids
organic super fruit punch and if you did
you wouldn't have withdrawals if you
stopped drinking it I'd be having Honest
Kids withdrawals I'm not gonna lie
Honest Kids withdrawals yeah that's what
I mean it's good I'm sure it's good
right yes I yeah so your name how do we
get to it uh [ __ ] it's a long story if
I'm summing it up like can we get the
mic uh closer yeah there we go there we
go there we go so like long story short
I was in school I was going through some
[ __ ] okay dipping dad and [ __ ] I felt
like that was bad for me what were you
doing
just so like that [ __ ] had me feeling
crazy I felt like if I kept doing that I
would destroy myself then before that I
spent a bunch of time by myself so I
just called myself lonely because I
really was by myself I was homeschooled
spent a lot of time in the crib [ __ ] wow
yeah so quite a literal name very little
yeah
what uh was your drug of choice in
school Xanax designs man yep
was this prior to like the fentanyl
thing being a thing yeah this one drugs
were pure like it was like you know what
I'm saying You Miley was Miley museums
was like a freaking roulette I don't do
none of that [ __ ] that much no more
because I'm scared of that when you say
that much no more I still get high don't
Everybody Get High I mean we I I eat
shrooms and smoke weed I eat from the
smoke weed and that's all I do that's
what I mean I feel like you know what I
have heard though randomly that there's
like some weed that's laced with
fentanyl I don't know where they're
selling that [ __ ] at have you heard that
it's a thing that's terrifying I smoke
one weed though so that won't ever come
out with have you ever had a bad edible
experience I don't like Edibles I have
bad edible experiences every time I take
Edibles them she's making me that's the
worst the worst [ __ ] in the world I
don't understand like I have a homie
named James who'll eat like
50 milligrams a night wait James a
tweaker now he's a wild boy he's but he
says he just does it to go to sleep I'm
like bro I'd be [ __ ] hallucinating
puking every night like this stuff to
[ __ ] what's the worst edible
experience you had uh
I remember the first time I took Edibles
ain't a lot first time I was like really
smoking weed and [ __ ] like I was one of
them [ __ ] like we made made me anxious
so like when I first took edible I felt
like I was gonna die the very first time
I can't like fully remember but I just
remember being so scared I'm like bro
this is my last time right yo that
actually has happened to me many times
that [ __ ] is horrible I've been Edibles
three times and each time I was like you
know what let me try it one more time
maybe I just had a bad go at it
way worse than eating shrooms bro what
something you would think like
psychedelics would have a [ __ ] tripping
but that [ __ ] really like therapeutic
how um very therapeutic have you found
any therapy in doing psilocybin 100 I
micro dose often honestly so like that's
just what I'd be on you microdose right
before the interview yeah exactly yeah
and like on my tour I've been doing that
[ __ ] I've been making music like that uh
shrooms just the first time I did
shrooms when I tripped it was like an
actual learning experience for me so I
kind of use it for that right and then
with the micro dose and I just use it to
keep myself open throughout the day I
think of it as like a limitless build
yeah it's like that so when you would
you uh The Learning Experience you had
when you first tripped what was that
like [ __ ] it was just how I figured out
I haven't do all this [ __ ] I'm doing
right now wow so you feel like you
unlock something you you were 100 like
the first time I did shrooms and that's
it it's just like it kind of like I feel
like I tapped into the world more
understood like everything a whole lot
more that [ __ ] worked like overstanding
and understanding though like on the
surface end up under it did you uh
hallucinate at all no hell no off the
acid on an acid I definitely hallucinate
I had a bad trip because I took a double
dose tab for my first time so I was like
super tripping that was like the worst
[ __ ] that ever happened to me I feel
like I went through some [ __ ] called
like ego death yeah I don't even talk
about that [ __ ] on here but that was
crazy yeah yeah acid's more um visual
100 you do a lot of shrooms you just get
in your [ __ ] feelings you start
thinking about life facts certainly gets
a little more vibrant the lights are a
little more trippy but you like really
are in your [ __ ] head definitely it's
like I I call it a super blunt it's like
if you smoke the best weed yeah I like
that the super blunt that's fair